not a zombie apocalypse what if it was
like you were in urine lost or something
okay okay you're stranded on the desert
island
who who who would survive the longest
on a desert island yeah
you're in lost you've seen lost right
probably
probably me because i'm the most
familiar with like maybe wildlife and
just like dangerous [ __ ]
that's just the aussie yeah exactly i
would i would
alright out of the way i would
definitely eat something and die
[Music]
fishing
see the reason why i think you could
have an easier time surviving the zombie
apocalypse is because you almost get a
tangible benefit from being an [ __ ]
yeah being a piece of [ __ ] yeah but in
the desert island you have to actually
work together
yeah because if you're the [ __ ] that
you're the one that's going to be exiled
right yeah yeah and and you need as much
help as you can get you know joey's like
a few steps ahead whether you have like
a [ __ ] society now yeah of course
of course you're like
lord of the flies
you also want to be exiled
you can't steal people's food or
whatever right you can't go together
yeah on a zombie apocalypse you could go
steal someone's house can't that's true
that's true sorry gonna steal that stuff
from the house yeah that's true yeah but
yeah you're very limited on an island
right yeah you gotta work together you
can't really hide on an island one of
your fishes one of you
uh doesn't make a fire yeah
and one makes a house full of those
conversations making me like wanna just
learn a lot more survival survival tips
that's why we're in things that i don't
know now because you drink your piss
have you done that thank you very much
i do it all the time just to get ready
just in case you never know just wait
for a break filter in there that that
was that was wow
i watched the survival man thing he was
like uh even if you're on like a raft in
the ocean yeah you should never drink
your own piss
apparently you should never drink your
own pee
see like apparently it's no even if
you're super dehydrated apparently which
makes it worse but that's so conflicting
because it's either everything i've seen
about drinking your own pieces either
never drink your piss or always drink it
it is it is
no i agree i agree
i i i
i weird i've actually had the same
thought where i'm like this is so
conflicting one minute one minute
backgrounds is absolutely like smashing
his own piss down like it's a bad would
recommend 10 out of 10. then there's
another time
absolutely do not drink your own piss
every
do you think on like the scale of there
should be like a drink pissing scale
there
should be a middle ground on whether we
should be drinking or not there's a lot
of misinformation about pee drinking
that i think needs to be corrected there
is never a video that i have seen where
the guy's like mate you may consider
drinking your pizza it's always like you
think under circums certain
circumstances no maybe you should be
able to drink piss
i think it's about filtering it you need
to find a way to filter it
but there's one time where
he
pissed in a snake
while i was alive
not while i was like
well yeah i think he was a dead snake
that he'd killed i think can you do all
this and he turned it into like a water
sack right right
and i think i don't know how
i don't know i don't know how this just
sounds like a meme this does
it's like a parody of the bear girls
video
yeah and i think it filters it or
something somehow or makes it somewhat
edible or i don't know what was it
better grills i don't know what they
like use condoms as like a device to
hold water or i might just like it
probably yeah
i i don't i don't know why that way
like i don't know back rails you talk to
a desert island with condoms oh just
have a seat have a seat back rails
you brought hard mike's lemonade and
condoms to their dessert island huh
look now what do we have here it's the
condom tree
i don't know if there's like a condom
off this
it's just a cyanide and happiness
are very useful for holding bodies of
water in case you need to survive i
don't know who said that to me or if
it's bear grylls or not but i wasn't
just like a youtube channel it'd be real
annoying getting that lube out of that
condom man
why why are we pissing in the snake
again
to survive
he's said to have required the
additional liquid as a last resort for
water
so basically survival instinct which is
what we're arguing here i'm not saying
like you should drink your piss on a
sunday morning i'm saying like they had
giant tortoises
i have one liter
i'm going on a desert island i'm hoping
it's the one desert island that has the
last remaining like giant daughters of
like what do you bring to a deserted
island
one giant tortoise family a family of
giant tortoises that i can breed so i
can sustain myself forever
oh my god
oh my god have you guys seen like
nathan's like talking about piss
drinking have you guys ever seen nathan
for you no
oh someone where he
like tries to fix their business yeah
yeah it's one where he tries to fight oh
i thought this is really good i really
want to watch it it is a really good
show so it's kind of like um so it's
uh i don't know what the actor's name
but the character he plays is nathan and
he tries to fix these businesses yeah
with like the most
like out of the box dumb idea possible
right and like
part of like what makes the show funny
is him pitching these ideas these
failing businesses so it's kind of like
you know uh like what sasha baron cohen
does like he puts people in ridiculous
situations and sees how they react right
and i think
like one of my favorite tv moments of
all time was possibly like
the only time
that i've seen him like break character
or almost break character because he was
talking to this guy um this this this
old guy and um he randomly i can't
remember the exact
uh context of the conversation but he
randomly brings up like piss uh like a
jar of piss or something right just to
try and shock the guy okay um and the
guy goes oh yeah like i i drink jar of
pissers all the time
[Laughter]
and you could tell like it was like the
most unscripted amazing piece of moment
on tv i've ever seen where nathan's like
what did you just say he's just like
yeah like sometimes like i i
i have like my grandchildren's piss just
lying about sometimes i take a swig
you you need you need to watch this clip
like because it in context is hilarious
out of context it's still hilarious it's
the only time this like nathan comes
close to like breaking breaking
character because he's hearing something
shocking why is it why is it that
immediately in my head i was like
drinking your own piss haha hilarious
drinking your children's piss what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you like as if it's
like worse
it's just completing the cycle of life
they came out of you
you're going back in
you're taking it back
so [ __ ] up
that's disgusting oh gross okay so you
go to a desert island yeah all right
you're on the plane that uh wilson's on
and uh what three items do you bring i
think his name was wilson
but the ball's name was wilson yeah
tom hanks character right yeah no that
wasn't his name it was the ball's name
yeah i know but you're talking about
tommy
who cares about him wilson
uh so you can bring three items to
survive what are you bringing fire
starter
come on come on no you know what that's
a waste of an item just learn a waste of
money learn there
what if okay we're not counting giant
clubs
okay you can't bring your jack jack
that's it that's fine that gone it's
gonna run out yeah you get something
just like flint or something yeah well
the flint's gonna run out too
eventually i guess
but like okay you shouldn't rely on that
you should you shouldn't okay assuming
we're going now right without without
prior knowledge that we're going to be
crashing no you're going to be you're
going to be going like like the big
brother or some [ __ ] you're going to be
sent to this desert island a tent
you could take ten yeah i would take a
tent because i'm not [ __ ] collecting
bones to make a house [ __ ]
that thing just foreign i would love to
see you try and build a house
okay
let's let's tear us things down and what
are the other two
uh a knife
okay i think that's valid yeah
and
[Music]
a nice book
what a [ __ ] nice one joe's gonna die
day one he's gonna he's gonna
accidentally cut his tent and then rip
the book in half out of range and stab
myself
i would bring a knife
a
water filter
that can filter salt water too smart
smart
onto those lamps you can do that with a
leaf huh you can do that with a leaf
right just a piece of mist
[Music]
i think the one big thing you'd want to
take it's probably a fishing net i
thought that as well i was like fishing
rod or fishing net yeah you'd probably
want a really nice sized fishing net
sure yeah probably make your life a lot
easier mm-hmm true or maybe like a
fishing stick i feel like i feel like a
knife you can just make
you could make like a uh caveman-esque
one like a sharp rock yeah yeah i feel
like you could do that and that would do
maybe but i feel like a knife would make
things a lot easier i think but
using the knife you can make more knives
right how are you gonna start by making
the knife to begin yeah it's the first
knife that's like going to be the
hardest make unless you're like that one
guy on youtube who made like the knife
out of cardboard or something like that
yeah
which genome of tree do you want
i'll make it
can i take a boat
like a really nice yacht
i'll just take my six million dollar
mansion hey if i i'm pretty sure some of
these uh like rich billionaires would do
it why can't i do it
no one said the scale of items i i can
bring why can't i bring a boat well then
i'll bring a jet and get the [ __ ] out
let's assume it's like a minecraft
sandbox
there's no end to the ocean it just goes
on forever but i would like the boat
just because i'll just bring a house
there
i should bring a city
how are you going to bring the house how
are you going to bring a house on a boat
no you cannot
you cannot bring a house i'll [ __ ]
i'll [ __ ] houseboat i'll [ __ ]
float in up star with
[Applause]
perfectly reasonable that you can sail a
boat to a desert island well i don't see
why this is it not fair well then you
wouldn't need anything else because you
get to [ __ ] go back to the mainland
with the boat no one said you have to
stay there joey oh my god the
implication was you had to stay there
and survive okay if i'm staying there
and surviving yeah the entire magic mic
the collection on dvd
never get more
one who has them apparently
oh my god what would i actually bring
what would you actually bring probably a
fishing net yeah i said that i know i
know
i feel like i could make a spear out of
something but i also think that is a lot
of work and i'd rather just catch the
fish easy because i'm going to die
pretty soon if i don't get this food
yeah sure so i got a fishing net mm-hmm
uh character prius would be
very economical
what else okay what's like the perfect
strap what's the optimized strap
and that's pretty good knife is [ __ ]
don't bring a knife what the [ __ ] that i
feel like i feel like a knife enables
you to make more tools needed to survive
faster
yeah yeah
i think fishing then the knife is like
the guy like because you can make a
knife but like
like in order to craft a knife i feel
like that would take a lot of effort but
a knife is so useful that it can help
you craft other tools too fast as well
fast as well i feel like a wind-up torch
would be super useful actually oh yeah
yeah cause like how let's be honest here
you're not gonna [ __ ] do that indiana
jones
it's just not it's not gonna work why
how do you how are you gonna make that
you don't have oil huh those are like
oil rags soaked in like a ball yeah how
you can't make one of those normally i
just sweat onto it i don't know how
you'd make that how would you make one
of those things
i'm sure maybe like i don't know there's
maybe like some life hack where you use
like trees or some [ __ ] you know maybe
but like do you really want to be
[ __ ] around harvesting tree sap when
you could well you're probably going to
be harvesting other [ __ ] right
but like what would you want to be doing
in the night time anyway because if you
would stuck on a desert island
yeah it's gonna be pretty much you see
something maybe you wanna if i see
something oh also rope rope actually i
wanna make my own rope oh that's true
like an act like a good [ __ ] rope
yeah yeah yeah
like a really good one but i feel like
rope is i mean rope is obviously useful
if you if you only know how to make rope
huh do you know how to make a rope i
don't but do do you know how to make a
fire
i i can learn how to make a fire do you
know how to make a knife
yeah i can make a knife start bashing
[ __ ] together
but like if you can learn how to make a
fight you can learn how to make rope
right no no no i feel that's different
the rope is so hard
you've got to make these like individual
strands and then i don't even know how
you do that and then you have to start
wrapping that how do you
know what
i swear to god what is the base
ingredient to a rope base ingredients
what is a rope i swear to god i've seen
like ropes on huge like youtube
tutorials being made by like massive
leaves and like like
it's like tiny strands how do you like
them
are you really gonna want to like you
know rely on that though like when it
breaks like [ __ ] sake what if the rope
you bring breaks
how how would you break a rope gone with
as much rope as you want well
give me your length
of knives
you can't
what is what what is more than one knife
i will tie the rope on one side of like
the [ __ ] city i'm leaving from and
then i'll [ __ ] hurt
myself back up like
you could barely cycle across the shimon
army kaido how are you gonna pull
yourself back via rope
this is this is i feel like i would be
interested to do like not not a complete
like a desert desert island survival
okay we should do this we should do a
survival where we take the items that we
said i'll take a bro for fishing net and
a knife and you can take
um was it uh rope no not rope knife it
was knife knife tent in a nice book
that's right nine send a nice board with
pretty comfortable and dant would take
nothing she's an idiot all right water
filter for salt water and you didn't
mention the last one uh i said fire
starter
fire started
yes that's what i would take
what would you use to start the fire
though with the fire starter what do you
mean because usually fire starters work
because you already have like a
pre-existing light right so where are
you gonna get that from no like you
there's there's like
there's like five starters kits
available that make it easier to start a
fire right then you know using the raw
materials there right but getting that
initial spark is the hard part right
i mean have you guys ever made a fire
before once
yeah once
when
like ages ago when they did the the
[ __ ] yeah i did the ropes yeah i did
the rope where did you learn how to do
that we when we had like those uh like
schools
i never got taught this in school that's
all like i never had like a [ __ ] like
rival if you'd rope can't you make that
fire a lot easier
how much fruit are we talking about how
thick is this rope
i i would probably side with a thicker
rope though actually so it wouldn't be
it wouldn't work
but you could also the good thing about
rope is that you could let's say if you
had a really long rope yeah that's cut a
piece
and then start peeling off the
individual strands that make the thick
rope and then you've got a smaller rope
now
[Music]
right
this is just three idiots
talking about surviving
three idiots with zero survival
knowledge talk about surviving on a
desert island now i just want to do a
video where we should yeah